Rony the limo driver wants to show us
his collection of dildos or something or
his [__] rings [__] rings are his thing
aren't they I'm here hey how you doing
Ron all right man how's it going
everyone's at [__] go [__] yourselves
what is this tour I'm gonna give us yeah
I got my whole thing here this is like
one of those unwrapping videos yeah
these are some of the [__] rings let me
see that hold that up I can't see it so
I'll take I'll take them out it's easier
it's better to see that a plastic is one
[__] ring can you get that Robin imagine
that like something that came out of a
car distributor cap like you know like a
bit like a big nut is this one doughnut
it's a swollen yes boy a bagel yeah
exactly
[Laughter]
these favorite yeah patience Robin
patience she likes these there's three
different sizes of these they come in
three sizes small medium and pool float
let me go on to the next one oh I think
I know what happened a dental fell on my
keyboard hold on looks like it has a
battery attached yeah it's got a little
vibrator if I don't hear it there goes
you notice a [__] ring with a vibrator
yeah yeah I'm like the toys-r-us of [__]
look at all these toys I got you
certainly are this is whoa hold on let
me get it this is this is like a
jackhammer for my ass oh look is that
the thing you stick in your [__] this
is the toy we play with oh my god you do
with that thing you know what that looks
like the base of a lamp how deep do you
get that into your [__] um probably
like here wow my god
I run well thanks for the wait wait wait
this is not all I got when it goes in my
[__] and comes out my ear wait a
second I gotta find we haven't tried
this yet it's like a harness that you
put on you put on her look at that thing
it's the harness that goes on her and if
you take it from behind
it's like riding a horse you know what
I'm saying it's like pulling a carriage
you know you know in other words you're
not now yeah and then this thing this
thing I this thing is weird I find this
thing weird but yeah it's it's a ball
bag finally something Ronnie finds weird
yes it's weird and what is a ball place
weird it's got it's got this little
round thing that stretches and you put
your balls just you squeeze your balls
into it and you turn on the switch and
it vibrates your balls oh wow this what
this one is weird
is it weirder than the other one I'm a
good thing and I think you just cured me
of enjoying sex honestly